Robert Rodriguez made his first film el
Mariachi when he was 23 for a legendary
$7000 last year he remade it for seven
million dollars as desperado with
Antonio Banderas his vampire action
flick from dusk till dawn written by and
starring Quentin Tarantino opens in May
Rodriguez is one of the hottest young
directors in Hollywood and certainly the
cheekiest he agreed to give us an
exclusive high-energy masterclass in how
to make your first film on virtually
nothing
good morning class now filmmaker famous
filmmaker a while back said something
about everything you need to know about
film you can learn in about a week he
was being generous we can learn it in 10
minutes set your watches we'll be out of
here in 10 kids okay so you want to be a
filmmaker
yeah wrong you are a filmmaker the
moment you think about that you want to
be a filmmaker you're that make yourself
a business card this is you're a
filmmaker passing out to your friends as
soon as you get that over with and you
got it in your mind that you're one
you'll be one you'll start thinking like
one don't dream about being a filmic you
are a filmmaker now let's get down to
business let's play it's not enough in
this business you have to become
technical creative people are born
creative you're lucky technical people
however can never be creative it's
something they'll never get you can't
buy and find it study it you're born
with it too many creative people don't
want to learn how to be technical so
what happens that become dependent on
technical people become technical you
can learn that she creative and
technical you're unstoppable experience
do you have experience in movies you do
write you watch movies now you need to
have movie experience not gonna learn
from just watching movies you learn some
things you learn more picking up a
camera by making your own films your own
mistakes mistakes don't have to be
mistakes everything is subjective a
mistake to one person is actually a
piece of art to someone else hide behind
that tell everyone it's art you can get
away with a lot
start with a screenplay does anyone here
know how to write no good everyone else
writes the same way start writing your
way that makes you unique you can take
writing classes that's good but don't
bother to go to film school or you'll be
making films like everyone else we want
to see new film how do you write a
script well you obviously don't have a
lot of money or you wouldn't be in my
class so you want to make a movie you
don't want to spend a lot you're gonna
come up with problems every day on your
set you can get rid of the problem one
or two ways you can do it creatively or
you can wash it away with the money hose
you got no money you got no hose so
let's make a screenplay for a movie that
you can actually make without having to
make your parents poor let's make a
cheap movie how do you make a cheap
movie look around you what do you have
around you take stock in what you have
your father owns a liquor store make a
movie about a liquor store you have a
dog make a movie about your dog your mom
works in a nursing home make a movie
about a nursing home when I did anybody
a key I had a turtle
I had a guitar case I had a small town
and I said well I'll make a ruby around
that I mean a dime yes how do you
visualize a movie when storyboards you
can do that you can pre visualize your
movie and draw amount but you should
really do it was just make a blank
screen for yourself and sit there and
watch your movie close your eyes and
stare at this imagine a screen imagine
your movie shot-for-shot cut for cut sit
there close your eyes and get rid of
everybody get rid of all the thoughts in
your head except your movie and watch
your movie is the to slow is it too fast
is it funny does it make sense watch it
and then write down what you see write
down the shots that you see and then
just go get those shots
equipment okay let's go to equipment the
worse the better you don't want anything
too fancy remember this is your first
movie you're not Spielberg yet I used
this one for El Mariachi almost the same
one this is a 16 M I use it a 16 s but
this is exactly what I had it helped me
move fast because it was light it was
very noisy so I had to do the sound in
the wacky way but this thing here would
cost you about $2,000 don't spend that
kind of money find some monkey who owns
one I found somebody who had one of
these sitting around he wasn't using it
I borrowed it from him I shot my own
movie this is a nice stand it's a very
solid stand you know what's gonna happen
the camera is gonna stay on the stand
you're gonna just keep it there coz it's
so nice meaning your movies gonna look
stiff take it off of there sit in a
wheelchair push yourself around get some
energy in your film that's the great
thing about first films they have so
much life and so much energy big
productions can't even duplicate that
energy because they've got two good
stand they've got too much crew and
everything's really smooth and polished
and it's lifeless add life to your film
by taking getting rid of the fancy stuff
too good too heavy too good just use
your hands better
here's a light meter this isn't the
right one I broke them I have the one
this is a spot meter that's okay but
it's too fancy you just need one with a
little white dome on it point it to your
subject read the light look at the
number on your lighting me to remember
the light meters our friend feed that
into the to the lens and the iris and
then they're set you can start shooting
don't over like mariachi I had two
lights regular light bulbs they were
balanced for indoor film so it looked
fine in fact everyone said them lighting
look moody because there was very little
light so again your mistake your
shortcomings suddenly becomes artistic
expression finally post-production when
you finish shooting your movie what do
you do these are your friends my friends
video editing systems computer editing
systems anything like that it's
immediate it's easy it's cheap do not
cut on film film is your enemy you may
be shooting on film but don't cut on
film of any of you want to cut off them
get out of my class right now go spend
$20,000 in a real film school and do
that you'll never get a job don't
believe me everything is on computers or
video these days film is slow film is
expensive film is not creative film
takes too long cut on tape that's what I
did I shot mariachi for nothing I added
it on video I had a three quarter inch
master that looked beautiful because the
negative was transferred right to tape
there was no middle man so it looked
like 35 millimeter clean pristine
colorful imade VHS copies of this sent
him out all over Hollywood I never made
a film print waste of money you have to
string them up they get worn out they're
expensive they're copies of your
negative you don't want that you don't
want copies of your negative you want
your negative on tape where people can
duplicate it and watch it and get you
work okay so you've made your movie
you've cut it you've got it
out people want you what do you do first
thing you want to do is get an agent
right away
Hollywood is full of sharks you need a
shark working for you these guys go and
they get you the best deals and they get
you the best prices and they get you the
best movies what you've learned is
something no one else has how to make a
movie dirt cheap no one else in
Hollywood knows how to do that you guys
can make them cheap you guys can make
them better don't get swallowed in the
system
take advantage your position now I make
movies that are still low budget but
they look like big-budget movies because
I learned the techniques that I just
showed you today I have all day I've
gotta go back and use my own films so
hope you guys learn something today I
hope you grab some of these cameras and
go shoot something of your own I hope
you write down the ideas that you have
the dreams that you have stop aspiring
start doing get to it see you in
Hollywood be scary